Quiero llevarlos a un viaje al lugar donde me crie,
llamado Dir, en el noroeste de Pakistán.
Dir fue fundado en el siglo XVII.
Fue un estado principesco hasta su unificación con Pakistán en 1969.
Nuestro príncipe, Nawab Shah Jahan, había reservado el derecho de vestir de blanco,
el color del honor, pero solo para sí mismo.
No creía en educar a su gente.
Y en el momento de mi nacimiento, en 1979,
solo un 5 % de los niños y un 1 % de las niñas
recibían enseñanza escolar.
Yo estuve entre ese 1 %.
Al crecer, era muy apegada a mi padre.
Es un médico de farmacia y me envió al colegio.
Cada día, al terminar mis lecciones, iba a su consultorio.
Es un hombre maravilloso, y un líder de la comunidad muy respetado.
Lideraba una organización para la asistencia social,
y yo iba con él a las reuniones políticas y sociales
para escuchar y hablar con los hombres locales
sobre nuestros problemas sociales y económicos.
Sin embargo, cuando cumplí los 16 años,
mi padre me pidió que dejara de ir con él a las reuniones públicas.
Ahora era una mujer joven, y mi lugar estaba en el hogar.
Me sentí muy molesta.
Pero la mayoría de los miembros de mi familia apoyaban esta decisión.
Fue muy difícil para mí,
sentarme en casa y no estar involucrada.
Pasaron dos años
hasta que finalmente mi familia accedió a que mi padre me reconectara
con otras mujeres y chicas,
para que pudieran compartir sus problemas y poder resolverlos juntas.
Así que, con su bendición,
empecé a reconectarme con mujeres y chicas
así podíamos resolver juntas sus problemas.
Cuando las mujeres se presentan,
traen sus realidades y puntos de vista.
Y, sin embargo, encontré muy a menudo
que las mujeres subestiman su propia fortaleza,
su potencial y su autorrespeto.
Sin embargo, al conectarme con estas mujeres y chicas
me quedó muy claro
que si había alguna esperanza de crear una vida mejor
para estas mujeres y chicas, y para sus familias,
debíamos defender nuestros derechos,
y no esperar a que alguien viniera a ayudarnos.
Así que decidí arriesgarme
y fundé mi propia organización en 1994,
para crear nuestra propia plataforma para potenciar a las mujeres.
Llamé a muchas mujeres y chicas para que trabajaran conmigo.
Fue duro.
Muchas de las mujeres que trabajaban conmigo debían dejarlo cuando se casaban,
porque sus esposos no las dejaban trabajar.
Una de mis colegas había sido entregada por su familia
como compensación por un crimen que había cometido su hermano.
No la pude ayudar.
Y en ese momento me sentí muy impotente.
Pero eso me convenció aún más para continuar con mi lucha.
Vi muchas prácticas como esta,
donde estas mujeres sufrían en silencio, soportando esta brutalidad.
Pero cuando veo una mujer
luchando por cambiar su situación en lugar de rendirse,
eso me motiva.
Así que me postulé para un cargo público
como candidata independiente en el distrito del Bajo Dir
en las elecciones locales de 2001.
A pesar de los desafíos y obstáculos que enfrenté durante este proceso, gané.
(Aplausos)
Y estuve en ese cargo público durante seis años.
Pero, desafortunadamente,
a nosotras, las mujeres electas,
no se nos permitía sentarnos en el concejo con todos los miembros
y participar en los debates.
Debíamos sentarnos en una sala aparte, solo para damas,
sin saber lo que pasaba en el concejo.
Los hombres me dijeron:
"Uds., las mujeres electas,
deberían comprar máquinas de coser para mujeres".
Y yo sabía que lo que más necesitaban era el acceso al agua potable.
Así que hice todo lo que pude
para dar prioridad a los desafíos reales que enfrentaban estas mujeres.
Instalé cinco bombas manuales en los dos pozos secos de mi localidad.
Bien, conseguimos que funcionaran otra vez.
En poco tiempo hicimos que 5000 familias tuvieran acceso al agua.
Probamos que cualquier cosa que pudieran hacer los hombres
nosotras también podíamos hacerlas.
Hice alianzas con otras mujeres electas,
y el año pasado
nos permitieron sentarnos con todos los miembros del concejo.
(Aplausos)
Y participar en la legislación, en el planeamiento y en el presupuesto,
en todas las decisiones.
Vi que ser numeroso fortalece.
Ya lo saben.
La ausencia de representación significa que nadie lucha por Uds.
Pakistán es...
está a casi 13 000 km de donde estoy hoy aquí, con Uds.,
pero espero que lo que les contaré resonará en Uds.,
aunque tengamos esta gran distancia en kilómetros y en nuestras culturas.
Cuando las mujeres se presentan
traen con ellas la realidad y las esperanzas de media población.
En 2007 vimos el ascenso de los talibanes
en Swat, en Dir y en los distritos cercanos.
Fue horrible.
Los talibanes mataron a gente inocente.
Casi todos los días
la gente recogía en las calles los cadáveres de sus seres queridos.
La mayoría de los líderes políticos y sociales
que luchaban y trabajaban para mejorar sus comunidades
fueron amenazados y atacados.
Incluso yo tuve que irme,
y dejar a mis hijos con mis suegros.
Cerré mi oficina en Dir y me trasladé a Peshawar,
la capital de mi provincia.
Estaba traumatizada, pensando en qué era lo siguiente que debía hacer.
Y la mayoría de los miembros de mi familia y mis amigos
sugerían: "Shad, deja de trabajar.
La amenaza es muy seria".
Pero persistí.
En 2009, tuvimos una afluencia histórica de personas desplazadas internamente,
desde Swat, Dir y otros distritos cercanos.
Empecé a visitar los campamentos casi todos los días,
hasta que las personas desplazadas internamente
comenzaron a regresar a su lugar de origen.
Establecí cuatro unidades de salud para madres e hijos,
especialmente para cuidar de las más de 10 000 mujeres y niños
de los alrededores de los campamentos.
Pero durante todas estas visitas
observé que las necesidades de las mujeres recibían muy poca atención.
Y busqué la razón detrás de eso.
Y encontré que se debía a que las mujeres estaban poco representadas
en las plataformas sociales y políticas, y en nuestra sociedad en su conjunto.
Y en ese momento me di cuenta
de que debía centrarme exclusivamente
en construir y reforzar el liderazgo político de las mujeres
para aumentar su representación política,
de manera que en el futuro pudieran tener su propia voz.
Así que empezamos a entrenar a unas 300 mujeres y jóvenes
para las elecciones inminentes de 2015.
¿Y saben qué?
El 50 % de ellas ganó.
(Aplausos)
Y ahora están sentadas en los concejos,
tomando parte activa en la legislación, el planeamiento y el presupuesto.
La mayoría de ellas invierten sus fondos
en la salud de las mujeres, educación, capacitación y agua potable.
Todas estas mujeres electas
ahora comparten, discuten y resuelven juntas sus problemas.
Les contaré sobre dos de las mujeres con las que he estado trabajando:
Saira Shams.
Esta mujer joven de 26 años
se presentó como candidata en 2015 en el Bajo Dir, y ganó.
Completó dos de los esquemas de infraestructura de la comunidad.
Ya saben: mujeres... esquemas de infraestructura de la comunidad...
Algunos piensan que este es un trabajo de hombres.
Pero no, es también un trabajo de mujeres, también podemos hacerlo.
Y también reparó dos de los caminos que conducen a las escuelas para niñas,
porque sabía que, sin acceso a ellas,
estas escuelas son inútiles para las niñas de Dir.
Y otra de las jóvenes es Asma Gul.
Ella es un miembro muy activo del fórum de líderes jóvenes que establecimos.
No pudo postularse para un cargo público,
así que se convirtió en la primera mujer periodista de nuestra región.
Habla y escribe sobre los problemas de las mujeres y las chicas y sus derechos.
Saira y Asma son ejemplos vivos
de la importancia de la inclusión y la representación.
También les diré esto:
en la elección general de 2013 en Pakistán
y en las elecciones locales de 2015
hubo menos de 100 votos femeninos en Dir.
Pero ¿saben qué?
Estoy orgullosa de decirles que este año, durante las elecciones locales,
hubo 93 000 mujeres que votaron en Dir.
(Aplausos)
Así que nuestra lucha está lejos de haber terminado.
Pero este cambio es histórico.
Y es también una señal de que las mujeres están luchando,
apareciendo y dejando en claro
que todos debemos invertir en la creación de un liderazgo femenino.
En Pakistán, y aquí, en los EE. UU.,
y en cualquier lugar del mundo,
esto significa mujeres en política, mujeres en negocios
y mujeres en posiciones de poder tomando decisiones importantes.
Me tomó 23 años llegar aquí.
Pero no quiero que a ninguna chica o mujer
le lleve 23 años de su vida para hacerse oír.
He tenido algunos días oscuros.
Pero he pasado cada día de mi vida
trabajando por el derecho de cada mujer a vivir a su capacidad máxima.
Imaginen junto conmigo un mundo
donde miles de nosotras nos levantamos
y apoyamos en conjunto a otras jóvenes,
creando oportunidades y opciones que beneficien a todos.
Y eso, mis amigos, puede cambiar el mundo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)